well there are definitely some tech
smart seniors out there but one man says
his lack of tech savviness landed him
thousands of dollars short the 75 year
old veteran is sharing his story in
hopes others in his position don't fall
for the same tricks Ryan Matthey shows
us
here you go this is what I want you to
see Ernest Harris III balances his
checkbook online every morning it's
become daily routine for the 75 year old
since his time as an army combat Medic
in the late 60s due to my occupation in
Vietnam I was exposed to Agent Orange
the exposure leaving him battling a
plethora of medical problems now he's
fighting a new battle and that's where
you are trying to reach is no longer in
service he says his computer locked him
out one morning a message on the screen
giving him a phone number supposedly for
Apple security when he called multiple
Representatives already knew his name
and that he was locked out the man on
the other line claimed hackers were
using his info to open accounts on child
pornography websites the senior saying
he was directed to withdraw all the
money in his savings before hackers did
with nearly 34 thousand dollars in hand
he says he was directed to two different
Bitcoin machines one of them here in a
Central Valley strip mall it was the
last time he says he saw that money and
when he tried filing reports with police
and the FBI because I'm the one who went
up there and got it
they couldn't do anything about it
housing in general has gotten more
difficult Harris fearing he will now
lose his home Trista Dowd with U.S vets
Las Vegas says they're seeing an
increase in senior vets looking for
housing after scams we have sometimes
families with children arrive thinking
they're going to be moving into housing
as soon as they get here come to find
out you sent somebody a couple thousand
dollars and there was never a unit
eventually in the next couple months
that's when it's really when I'm not
able to do what I for the house payment
and all that you know
um that's when it's going to really
start kicking in
now the Federal Trade Commission says
hackers use those kind of fear tactics
to get information over the phone
they'll commonly ask for a payment via
gift card a transfer app or
cryptocurrency now reputable agencies
will not ask for any of this especially
over the phone they say family of that
veteran who was featured in our story
has created a GoFundMe to help him you
can find that on our website